i
[Música]
y
la policía de bolivia ha puesto en
marcha una unidad de género interna para
hacer seguimiento a los casos de
violencia en contra de las mujeres
policías o aquellos casos en los que los
policías hombres son acusados de cometer
estos delitos esta unidad se ha
establecido hace tres meses y está
indagando tres casos pero no tiene
funciones punitivas lo que hace es
investigar el caso y pasarlo hacia la
fiscalía o hacia estrados judiciales por
otro lado la unidad tiene la misión de
hacer un trabajo de concientización con
policías hombres y con mujeres de la
importancia de tener una vida libre de
violencia donde no existan feminicidios
acoso laboral o violencia sexual en
bolivia hasta la fecha se han presentado
52 feminicidios sin embargo en los
últimos meses no se han conocido de
casos en los que los policías estén
implicados en la comisión de estos
delitos pero en años anteriores si hubo
policías y militares involucrados en
feminicidios en el país
[Música]
en argentina la violencia de género el
interior de las fuerzas policiales y de
seguridad es un problema que persiste a
pesar de la adopción de diversas medidas
para combatirla entre otras políticas en
2011 el gobierno nacional creó los
centros integrales de género para
recibir denuncias por violencia o abuso
laboral en las fuerzas federales y
algunas fuerzas provinciales adoptaron
iniciativas similares sin embargo en
2019 la red nacional de mujeres policías
había denunciado que una de cada tres
mujeres dentro de las policías de
argentina sufre algún tipo de violencia
de género por parte de sus superiores no
se trata sólo de avanzar sobre la
violencia física y el abuso en los
últimos 20 años también se eliminaron
restricciones por embarazo y los cupos
limitados de ingreso de mujeres a las
fuerzas sin embargo por ejemplo en la
policía bonaerense la policía más grande
del país
si bien el 40 por ciento de su cerca de
100.000 efectivos son mujeres eso no se
ve replicado en la asignación de puestos
jerárquicos donde las mujeres todavía
ocupan un lugar reducido
[Música]
el ecuador del subcomando general de la
policía nacional con poco de diferentes
unidades especializadas en violencia
contra la mujer violencia de género
medicina en niñez para levantar una
nueva normativa que se desarrollase de
varios meses un manual para investigar
corregir sancionar y crear nuevas
políticas relacionadas a caso de
violencia sexual contra mujeres policías
tanto fuera como dentro de la propia
fuerza consideradas como acoso sexual un
secreto abusos que reconocían desde su
existencia los oficiales quienes bajo
reservas se deben a conversar con
france24 una línea de acción que se ha
fortalecido con el nombramiento y
ratificación de la comandante general de
la policía la general
tania varela la primera mujer en
comandar la fuerza desde que se
permitiera el ingreso de mujeres en la
década 240 los oficiales que pusieron el
tema expresaron que por miedo las
mujeres policías no denuncian los casos
en los entes legales y son sumisos a las
órdenes en sus superiores quienes
regularmente serían los responsables de
supuestos casos de violencia sexual una
metodología de denuncia que podría
cambiar mientras que al menos 9.000
mujeres de un contingente de 53 mil
policías participan en mesas de género
para dar
cuáles son sus derechos
[Música]